there's just always that voice that was
like okay there could be something else
out there hey you wanna make some money
hey you want to be on a beach every day
your life I'm like I feel like this
might be too good to be true but you
have me sold so tell me more so can I
ask you you said that he swiped one too
many times
was it common for people to put these
machines on the credit card oh oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah I just had a Joe go down
my spine when you said get the machine
like you'll make the money back
you gotta believe you have to baby swipe
it down baby yeah that's that's exactly
welcome to fake guru welcome to coffee
Zillah today we're talking about tank
and water when you have Eddie here you
wanted to come on and tell us your
experience so tell us what's going on
all right well thanks thanks for having
me on your show here I think the I guess
I'd like to start off you know once once
I kind of realized you know for the most
part like what a scam was you know the
nigerian prince and you know all those
things like it seemed like you could
kind of stay away from that but like the
smarter the scammer became you know the
more difficult it was to they have and
that's that's the hardest thing to like
you know sometimes you just I don't know
they're they're in the same skin you
know you just can't pick them out all
the time so so for me when I
transitioned you know out of the
military I started let's start with a
little background so you were in the
military yeah yes I was in the military
and I was in the military for for a
couple of years most Randy army
yeah I was a combat engineer so like we
would go and play with demolitions and
blow stuff up and stuff like that you
know so it was nice it was pretty sweet
job and thank you pay your service by
the way oh thanks
and actually prior to that which kind of
pushed me towards getting into this in
the first place I I went to culinary
school and after culinary school I
thought you know okay so I kind of want
to you know get into a restaurant you
know kind of work my way up and you know
do all of that and maybe have a
restaurant you know whatnot but then
like things changed you know life
shifted and whatnot and then and then I
left I joined hold on hold on help us
get into your mind people want to know
who Eddie is for a second you went to
culinary school then became a combat
engineer that's a that's a rare breed I
don't think there were many of those so
so one of the things that that made it I
guess
difficult a lot of people thought that I
did that backwards which to me made
sense when they said it but then you
know at the time I thought well like I
was gonna join anyway just I guess I
just went to school first because
usually you know you'd like go to the
military and then you get out and then
you go to school and do something but
then I did it before and then I joined
and then people were like why'd you do
that you you're paying for it yourself
I'm like ah I don't know I like to cook
like what do you want from me
but yeah so then actually before before
I even went to culinary school I was a
wildland firefighter so yeah so when
when I was fresh out of high school my
buddy's dad he owned a company and he
was like hey you know you guys want to
come out on the trail with us like we're
gonna make a ton of good money
it was doing wildland firefighting and
so we went out there and we were like
you know off deep in the woods just
around like a thousand acre force fire
and isn't that like super dangerous yeah
la there's like the few seasons that I
worked out there there's like a handful
of people that died while I was out
there
I mean not like people that I was with
you know but like in like the general I
guess area of this you know in the state
or whatever right now you're holding the
record for the most unique job history
that I've ever heard you know yeah I
guess I wanted to be a
jack-of-all-trades I don't know whatever
scammed by one ski yeah scam by one so
then I ended up I did that then went to
school and then join the military and
then after that I got out and I just
decided well all of my experience is you
know still in the kitchen and so I went
back and started cooking again but for a
restaurateur so for restaurants and then
I also work for a company called high V
do you guys have high V out there no
like it's kind of like Safeway do you
have Safeway out there oh you'd like a
grocery store yeah it's a grocery store
okay yeah so I was like like one of the
one of the like store chefs so like I
would go out and I do demonstrations of
food and you know things like that and
probably a year into it you know I
really like my job and I guess I mean
honestly I was having like a good amount
of fun but then at the same time there's
just there was just always that voice
that was like hey like there could be
something else out there hey you want to
make my money hey you want to see a dead
body
yeah that's that's pretty much that's
how it was and I kept telling myself
like I
no if I can I just don't have that
personality you know like I'm just not
the salesman like my dad was a salesman
but I never could be because I just I
don't know like I'm persuasive with
charm I'm not persuasive with you know
already yeah so anyway so I was about a
year into this job and then I decided
well like I I kind of want to look for
something else and I was on Facebook
like I was saying and I there was like
some ad that I came across and in the ad
the guy essentially they didn't say like
the ads that you see a lot now or like
you know Amazon you know selling on
Amazon FBA or like drop shipping or a
lot of you know stock trading and stuff
like that
and in the ad that I saw it was like
really really vague and they essentially
just said like hey you want to be on a
beach every day your life and I'm like I
feel like this might be too good to be
true but you have me sold so tell me
more so yeah so eventually and I
actually ended up saving like the page
that it was on so I could go back to it
to check it and a couple of days later I
went back and I was like okay okay let's
let's take a look at it so I go in and
then there was a it was essentially like
you sit in on a webinar and it was not
like the master class but it was like
they called it like the what is that
like the bastard mind group right
and so you master something master of
none yeah and so you'd go in there and
they give you the spiel of you know what
they're trying to do and really it just
came down to like you know they're
selling hope slash freedom slash
probably a product that maybe you could
sell if you're good enough
wait so at this point this point you
really don't even know what they're
selling no so there that's amazing to me
nicely so mind blowing that's that's the
biggest thing that I was like in the
beginning I thought oh man like whatever
it is you know as long as I can sell
something like then you know then I can
make money selling or whatever like I'm
just I'll be selling something whatever
sure but then because they were so vague
it ended up being like you know there
were a lot of people that were like wait
a minute
cuz they so in the webinars they have
like a little chat bar and on in the
chat bar there'd be people typing and
they're like everybody get out it's an
MLM like it's a it's a pyramid scheme
get out of here and the people running
the running the video they're like
alright if we see anyone say pyramid
scheme again like we're just gonna start
banning all of you ah we're going to
close this chat down nowhere yeah it was
like that's a bad sign whenever you have
to censor the comments to say don't say
pyramid scheme yeah that is a very bad
yeah it didn't make any sense because
like they were saying that they're like
they started calling on some of the
other people that were like already in
it they're like hey go there and shame
them like get them out like they can't
be doing that like don't let them say
that stuff that's all of us innocent
people right all of us hard-working
innocent Americans were like hey
like can you just tell us what we're
selling like tell me what it is it's
funny because like that is such a
uniquely MLM thing like I can't think of
another product even even like gurus and
stuff like that they tell you what
you're selling yeah
and though things are so weird like that
aren't they I've been to a few MLM
seminars and trying to get them to
explain their compensation plan and how
you actually get paid is so convoluting
teeth it's a possible and and the crazy
thing is so like when it's when when I
finally got to like the meat of it right
the only time that you knew what you're
gonna sell is after you bought what you
were going to sell so you had to buy
into it and then you could start selling
it yeah that's so weird dude come on
yeah yeah so I I don't know I don't know
how much of a fool I was probably good
at you know good another one but it
ended up that I got on a call and it was
and pretty much an interview and the guy
that I talked to he made it seem like it
was an actual interview you know and so
he was talking about oh hey you know
like are you sure that you can commit to
something like this like this is really
gonna change life man like this is gonna
be crazy and hey Eddie are you sure you
can handle this much money I don't know
if you can handle it man I don't know if
you can handle so much money in your
pocket be careful because some people
say yes they're not ready for this level
of money it changes people and your life
by your own personal jet can you do that
yes I'm up to the task let's do it so
and so I get through the the phone
process and finally you know they they
give you the spiel of like okay we have
this line of products you can go you can
purchase one which was it was called the
Yukon which essentially was just a pill
like a supplement pill to be clear
you've now figured out that it's can get
water you've looked this thing up so no
because
as he was selling it to me like in the
phone call the only time that I found
out what it was was as he was like hey
look at this and then he started
shooting all these facts and it was a 25
minute phone call and so he pretty much
made it seem like you know he gave the
scarcity mentality you know to me like
oh hey you know we only got this you
know much time on the phone call like
you know really got to get through this
and so when he explained what it was
then like that was the first time that I
even knew what the product actually was
when he told me what I was buying and so
that's bizarre to me and when you got
pitched this it had you ever been
pitched an MLM before like did you know
what you're dealing with have you ever
been in an MLM so honestly not exactly
so in the beginning I thought you know I
thought that I could you know like I
said before like stay away from you know
scams like that or you know the the
Nigerian prince type of deal everyone
thinks that and see that that's what I
said once they you know evolved and they
know what to what to push on you what to
look for then they kind of know how to
sell it to you and so once once I find
out that that it's actually like you are
under a person they become your mentor
and then that person has a mentor and
that that person has a mentor and then
it goes on and on and on
up until the CEO or you know whoever and
he's pretty much like you know looking
at his numbers like oh cool we made this
many millions like awesome go back the
pool like it's no big deal to him but
for all the people like you know
underneath especially the people
starting out then it's like it just
seems like an impossible you know
hill to climb because like nobody's
gonna buy the machine
well many critics of MLM would say that
that is by design it's to make money for
the people at the top and yeah much
money for people at the bottom yeah and
like 99% of people in most and my limbs
don't make money
I've been studies done on this and you
know at this point when you buy in
you're just looking for a way out of
what you're kind of like humdrum job and
you're thinking I gotta find a way to
make more money or so pretty much yeah
like I was I was actually freshly
married at the time and so there no
details do here so stop are you still
married no okay yeah so is there is
there is there any relation I'm sorry to
hear that by the way is there any
relation or it was totally separate
issues what do you mean like between the
MLM and things not work Oh
somewhat and really I mean yeah really
it it kind of kind of put like an
unnecessary stressor on a lot of things
you know I feel kind of bad for ASCII we
don't have to talk about it if you don't
want to no no it's cool it's cool
so really because you know so freshly
being married and then I was like man
you know I really need to figure some
stuff out and try and take some you know
find a new avenue of you know making
that sweet millionaire Bank like however
I can which obviously doesn't exist like
that but you know I was I was like 24 so
I was like okay yeah I can do this but
so I buy into it and once I do then
really
the price of things and like all the all
the costs for for the products and stuff
like that like it all kind of starts to
escalate right once I get to the point
of you know breaking like this $2,000
threshold it became it became like okay
I kind of want to pursue this full-time
and so I left the job that I had you
spent $2,000 right and you quit your job
because of because of the $2,000 but
because of like like I felt like I
needed to spend more time oh you were
committing right right I was just
committing more to it and so I what I
pretty much did was did your team tell
you to do that your little hype team
that was with you they were didn't like
hey oh you're not gonna be serious until
you quit your job so so some of it was
like so people will come in fresh and
like even it's so weird cause like even
only being a few weeks into it you know
somebody new comes in and they're like
welcome this person like they just
bought in at this level or whatever I'm
like oh man they don't know anything yet
like this is I can't wait
and the worst part is I still didn't
know anything like what did I know
nothing we were we were all dummies but
in the chats a lot of the time it was
like yeah man working to fire my boss
like that's the whole point of you know
doing all this financial freedom for
everybody
but then slowly one by one sure enough
people start kind of dropping off and
people are like like one guy became
homeless and he was living in his car
and then like
like he just wasn't on Facebook anymore
like he was just gone like I don't I
don't know like you just got to drink
too much kangen water what happened to
him I don't know my best guess is he
swiped one too many times and had no
swipes left and and was yeah he I feel
like sometimes you know in in times of
desperation you'll kind of do whatever
you need to to keep you know making
yourself believe that it's gonna work
and in some of the webinars it was funny
because they would do this thing where
they'd be like you know hey you gotta
figure out like how you know we need to
sell like we need to do this you know we
need to keep bringing people in like
that's how you build your team that's
how you build wealth and everything by
the way it was based on this like crazy
system where you'd go from like there's
an alphanumeric system where you'd go
like 1 a 2 2 a 2 you know so on and so
forth up to like 6 and then they'd start
mixing in dashes and stuff and it was
like there were a lot of levels you know
to climb up to but apparently like at
the top of the mountain you would get a
check for the rest of your life even if
he just stopped selling stuff so
everyone was trying to shoot for that
right right can I can I ask you you said
that he swiped one too many times was it
common for people to put these machines
on their credit card oh oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah I just had a Joe go down my
spine when you said but but see that's
the thing like it wasn't only cards they
were like they would try and get you to
just like take out loans to like any way
that you could run credit get the
machine like you'll make the money back
you got to believe you have to swipe it
baby
so wipe it down baby yeah that's that's
exactly and that was like hold on pick
your mic back up you just knocked your
mic down a little bit cool gang yeah
that's yeah yeah that's perfect service
and really those one of the things that
kind of made it a little scary because
once you see people like they start
dropping off and you're like man either
so III had seen this firsthand either
the switch flips to the position of you
know oh hey that's one less person
that's one less person to compete with
or like you know you care about people
like you should even as a salesman like
you should have you know any kind of any
kind of you know human human feelings
left in you you know not just that in it
for the money
he still likes it wasn't a lot of human
feelings at the MLM like a lot of
cutthroat behavior or so later on into
it I found out that some of the people
ended up getting kicked out because so
once I got into the group that I was in
they it was it was a community of like
1,500 people or something like that
so pretty you know pretty good size and
they were working on this the software
where you could go in and you could like
do courses and like watch videos and
they do tips and whatever and once
people started seeing that that was
picking up some of the people that fell
off of that group started trying to like
cross across recruit some of those other
people to do their own thing and once
they started doing that then you know it
was the top you know top sellers going
at each other and then we're down here
like we just want to sell something like
what's going on and they're telling you
move over you
come over here where the money is
exactly you know and they're just trying
to pull you I just saw that with a
future net where this guy Ryan Connelly
was kind of cry accused of cross
promoting he denies it of course but I
have to say that it's an allegation it's
just an allegation but I do feel like a
lot of the people who you find that
really do well with MLM
they are not it's not their first MLM
it's not their first rodeo they've been
doing it for a very long time
and they usually are dragging kind of
people with them from thing to thing and
that's how they build up their network
is like being like hey you guys who are
with me at that like MLM over there that
failed MLM come over here come over here
come over here and so maybe it was that
people at the top or jumping ship or
something like they felt like oh we're
gonna go here see if we can make some
money here or I mean so cuz how many
water machines can you sell let's see
that's isn't that's the problem with
this like let's Herbalife you can sell
shakes for days you could sell shakes
forever because people keep buying
shakes with the water machine it seems
like you buy one you're done right right
so the the one thing that it seemed like
they kept doing is like they would go
and they would sell they called it what
did they call that a trifecta I call
that the trifecta and I was essentially
buying into there was a mobile water
machine no there was a machine that you
would put in your home like a stationary
one and then the pills and you could
just take those wherever you know and
once you bought in at that you would
jump up one full level but at the same
time like they made it seem like
everyone needed these machines you know
like that that's that's though why that
you've been fed and for some people
that's the lie that they kept beating
like that's so you really weren't
complete with just $1000 water machine
actually let's talk about how much they
cost with that because
I'm not as familiar with how much they
caused I know they're kind of expensive
but why don't you everybody yeah yeah so
let me I don't know why I still have my
charts so let me let's see so maybe
you're still holding on to help come on
Eddie yeah holding on to what what am i
hope order maybe that's how many people
are dude some people are now yeah you
know right see that that is definitely
one thing that - yeah I remember these
okay so there are a ton of different
models base price for let's see base
price for the one of the first ones
actually 3900 yeah yeah see you in the
door huh see see that face yeah that
just gets here like first couple of
chips you know they wash your tongue I
mean I don't that doesn't quench your
thirst there oh no no but that's what
your job kangin dude what's crazy to me
is you're getting water through your tap
for free yeah
so the Wow I don't know the the one
thing that was so it made me keep hope
but at the same time I was like man you
know I don't know if this is gonna work
like I just can't you know I can't sell
that price it's like it's like Kirby's
right the vacuum
those are like 1,200 bucks for a brand
new machine so but the difference is
like that last oh I mean a
good wild it you know it's like made out
of steel and whatever sometimes cast
aluminum you know anyway so sometimes
you know you'll see prices like this and
immediately the people were like I'm not
doing that like I'm I'm out like word
you know where do I get out of here most
people don't have $4,000 to drop like
that anyway no no and so the trick was
selling hope to you and so once they
sold the hope to you then you find out
like oh man that would be cool there
there was this exercise right where we
were inside of the community thing and
part of the paperwork that you'd fill
out or online paperwork it was like
described in the most detail your ideal
morning and they wanted location what
you were doing like what you were gonna
eat like as much detail as possible and
then that way it was ingrained in your
head where you're like oh man that's
exactly what I want all I got to do is
sell this machine I can get that oh cool
yeah take my money take it take it I
don't want it gimme freedom right
because what's four thousand dollars if
it means you're making ten thousand
dollars or twenty or a hundred thousand
dollars yeah and the terrible thing is
like the promise of that being
non-existent ended up falling on all the
people cuz it became like well if I
can't sell this like that's on me and
there were some people in the community
that made that very clear where they
were like I mean you know you just gotta
sell like I don't you know you can watch
all the videos you want but until you
sell like I can't really help you out
man hey how hard is it really to sell
four units a month come on Eddie oh yeah
four no no no six you need six out the
door they always do those stupid
equations that sound plausible but
aren't plausible like if you talk to ten
people a day and one of them
eyes you know oh you have to do is do
that six days in a row and you got six
trainers and sales managers always do
they always use that stupid math it
never actually works it's never that you
talked about never it never happens no
no it's it's like in their mind you know
in a perfect world they go ten for one
they're like yeah ten knows one yes you
know and if you get ten knows or like
eleven knows big deal you go into the
next ten you'll get two yeses and what a
lot of people need to understand too is
that not only is it's an expensive
machine I've done a little bit of
research by the way yeah good it's also
competitively out-priced
by like everybody else in the market so
it's not just that it's an expensive
like luxury machine a lot of competitors
they allege that they're doing very
similar things if not more at a lower
price point so it's hard to sell that no
matter how good a Salesman you are at
the end of the day if it's the same
product for less people just go with
that so I think you're right that it has
to come down to the hope because what
else what's the other advantage besides
that and that really is what I've
noticed from emmalin's they're sort of
the good salesmen the people who succeed
are masters at tapping into the the hope
the you shouldn't be satisfied you can
do better and with us you will do better
right there give me that vision for the
future even if it's not plausible right
and that's that's definitely the selling
point that they always had was an idea
you know like the possibility mmm
because at the end of the day you know
you think about it like well man you
know if I get laid off for whatever
reason which you know a lot of people
get laid off for almost no reason right
a lot of things happen mm-hmm and so
they kind of instill that fear into you
almost where you're like well I mean if
I get laid off like I'm screwed
like I need to start looking and doing
something why not start here like this
is a great opportunity
you got the paperwork for a loan though
cuz you know I need to apply for one I
don't have that cash and unfortunately
yeah a lot of people went down the
financial tube because one second here
because not only did they buy that first
machine they bought that second machine
which let's see there are a couple of
machines that they have oh actually you
know what I misspoke last time so this
is the the mobile machine which is 3900
you're stationary machine the k8 kangen
is 4900 along with your yearly
subscription to your supplements and
that's another
now there may be thousand depending on
what you get
so yeah just on products alone they can
upsell you almost 10 grand 10 grand
right there right in the door 10 grand
now that's basically and is that tied to
how like how much money you can make
basically the machines yeah so yes and
they base so they base your purchases
and purchases under your name on your
rank or your you know level whatever you
want to call it because as as your sales
progress that's how you progress and so
if you sell three machines that boosts
you and then also puts the person that
you sold them to in like like a starter
spot really so they get their first rank
you know but yeah that's that's that's
how you move up you sell now a lot of
people are gonna say hey isn't that a
job where you sell and you move up talk
about the what is commonly thought of
when it comes to Atma limbs which is the
focus on recruiting over actual sales so
the one thing that I did notice they
definitely wanted you to sell but at the
same time it wasn't just like it wasn't
just selling the product too
people that weren't interested in the
opportunity that we had I see so it's
like because it's like recruit selling
yeah so it was essentially like hey
check out this product or they were
really you know what ended up getting me
was you know the idea of the freedom and
all of that that's how they get you in
the door and then they're like oh yeah
all you got to do is sell these machines
so you might as well you know stick
around with us and then you can just
keep moving up like no big deal you know
no big deal no big deal yeah that's
that's how they made a scene I was like
he's hip easy whatever we fought a beach
man that eazy-e DZ how much money did
you make well walk us through now you
now you bought in so are you making
money when do you start making money
what do you start making that money
making that money so I had a there was a
side community that I was also part of
it was like why was it rescuing pandas
or some random thing I mean it's the
same company but like you know how those
top-tier guys were competing I kind of
you know slid over to one other one chef
that follow the rabbit hole you know and
so what ended up happening is I made I
made a little bit of sales on the other
side and it was like let's see
it was one set of the three machines and
you made I think it was 30% on that
which wasn't which was like a decent
amount of money at that time which I
sure let's see that was like I want to
say the let that last transaction was
like 3,500
I think that's non all the stuff that
they had sold yeah but the thing is once
once they started you know getting into
like hey we're revamping this community
you know making the system and stuff
there goes another upsell where they
ended up saying okay we're gonna launch
this system where ninety percent of it
is done for you ninety percent of it
like an automation think this is so
common yeah yeah they they're trying to
automate it automated Emma limbs yeah
yeah pretty much really I've hit the
21st century boy yeah it is a new age oh
man yeah and once they started once they
saw that let me guess
evil limbs finally figured out what
advertising is it's direct selling but
automated but automated yeah what's
better than automation yeah so the the
pitch was ninety ninety percent you do
ten percent of the work the ten percent
of the work was like a depleted uranium
ten percent because that was a whole lot
of lifting that you still had to do
because you still had to get leads you
know you still had to run ads you still
had to spend the money on ads like your
ad spend was Oh God at one point I
hadn't had spent per day of like
like 300 bucks like a day and what are
you trying to do so what is the ad so
he's written for you so there they tried
to do some like templates that had like
essentially just like ideas of like what
you could put in an ad you know they
they were like oh hey take our ad and
then just kind of head your face into
the beginning and the end of it and then
it'll be our faces that you know is
selling and then P so many people were
like oh that's great like we don't
really have to make the ads like this is
awesome but for me you know trying to be
you know as efficient as I possibly
could I just said well I think I'm gonna
try and make like my own full ad you
know try and make it more personable and
so that's what I ended up doing I just
made you know I was in Chicago I was
like I was just in the park and then I
just started you know filming and I was
like okay you know hey this is like our
opportunity blah-dee-blah
you know running the air or making me
I'd love to see this ad oh god man I
honestly I still have like the folder of
all that stuff and every time I turn the
computer on him like I delete it now
keep it on key I just leave it there
archive it and so like they would have
you run ads and really I'd say like 90%
of the because that we would get into
when they would do the the meetings it
was all essentially like how to run your
ads better so trying to get you more
efficient right but at the same time
like halfway through it somebody starts
crying like as they're giving their
testimonial and that I'm not gonna put
names out there but there was one guy
that was in the top
the whole thing and at one point he was
like I just I just gotta tell you guys
you know like I love you guys man like
this is the community to be in like Oh
God and then he's just just bawling his
eyes out trying to sell it harder and
harder like guys don't stop don't stop
my life depends on it
exactly exactly oh [ __ ] alright so
eventually you know you you you feel
like you've gotten wise to you know the
whole adspend thing cuz like you've
tried so many things I have like pages
and pages of different like sets and
things like that cuz it's all preset
stuff you'd set up all of your ads and
you know you'd run ads there were people
I mean way deeper than I was they'd be
running ad sets of like Oh God
they claimed they were claiming that
their ad sets were running it like five
thousand dollars a day five thousand
dollars a day they must be getting crazy
conversions on that I mean they had to
of otherwise I mean or they're lying
like I don't and and you know get the ad
and they come to a seminar or they sign
up right away or so so much like you
know the Golden Age of the Alex Becker's
and and whatnot you know you see the ad
you go to the free webinar you sign up
so you continuously get the emails like
hey we're going live in five minutes you
know whatever and expectant yeah oh yeah
hey you gonna be there yeah you like
this wolf bug yeah
he's Alex Becker over I mean it's the
age of the Alex Becker's the Golden Age
over just as an aside so I telling this
story I feel like I was in the
prehistoric age because Alex Becker was
like you know the successor
to all of this it seems like I don't
know like there's just so many new ones
I every time that I watch a video or
like right before the video no joke
yesterday I had seen five different
people running very similar ads of the
same thing like oh hey Amazon you know
FBA like we're doing drop shipping or
Amazon automation is the new thing
automation yeah yeah that oh yeah yeah
that definitely is nice money without
anything you don't need to do anything
hey don't you want free money and no
effort it's like the height of the
get-rich-quick scheme oh if you want to
do absolutely nothing and make money
well have we got a product for you oh
yeah disbelief right away do you know
how to look at a screen and just do
nothing
yeah do that what make millions oh sweet
okay so go out so go ahead it's about
you have the webinar right yeah so so
we'd have the webinar and you know they
would pretty much I mean they would just
keep they would just keep selling us on
you know the same thing over and over
again and the one the one thing that you
could always count on is them talking
about either or meditation and reading
books getting your lamborghini knowledge
you know and you're kidding no yeah I
mean really like I want to say a real
good majority of like the brainwashing
was like getting in the correct mindset
because they believed that if you could
visualize what you were gonna get of
course it would materialize of course I
don't what's that book
yeah there you go yeah or thinking girl
rich I mean it's a lot it's a lot of the
same thing the key to that is that the
implication is you don't need to know
how it's gonna work
hey no you're gonna get rich and you
don't need to understand how your
problem is that you haven't been
thinking about how wealthy you're gonna
be so keep thinking and also it's a way
to like self brainwash because if you're
constantly thinking about being rich
then obviously the the biggest thing not
to do is think about the possibility of
failure because now you're no longer
attracting the wealth right so it's a
way to self reinforce the the
brainwashing of oh you're gonna make
money hey you're gonna make money why
because you have to be thinking of
making money otherwise you're not gonna
make any money yeah yeah and that's
that's one of those things like they say
it so many times and then eventually you
actually believe it yeah you believe it
and then at some point you're like man
like is the road ever gonna end like am
I gonna get there know what you mean
what's insidious is that some people do
obviously right and that's the whole
attraction is you have all these mentors
who are talking about how much money
they made although they have every
incentive to inflate their numbers
everybody has an incentive to fake it
till you make it because you attract
people in MLM czar successful attract
more people so but then everybody then
the person you are under probably has a
mentor that's more successful so
everyone's kind of looking up going hey
am I ever gonna be up there and the
answer of course is probably not
actually there's like 99% chance not but
we just don't think in statistics what
humans are equipped to think logically
like that we're equipped to be
susceptible to sales psychology
persuasion magical thinking magical
thinking that's what the I mean you know
that's what a lot of these things are
based off of so yeah
yeah that's so once I started getting
towards the end of you know this this
whole thing the the guy that was above
me the guy that brought me in he ended
up he actually left and him and a pretty
big group of people left and they tried
to pursue something else like you were
saying before is probably you know a
very similar you know architecture of
things and so they left and they started
actually they started getting into
crypto and you know a lot like a couple
other MLM things that they're trying to
do yeah and once they did that then I
was like oh man there's a switch again
like is it one less that I have to deal
with you know is that one less person
that I have to compete with or is that
like was that a wealth of knowledge
that's now gone and now what do I do you
know I feel helpless but there was one
one person that I ended up talking to
for like a good while and he he was like
the most upfront person and the whole
thing but then any in the end I just
decided like I can't like I can't spend
any more money like I can't do it how
much money have you spent at this point
total I was just right at ten ten
thousand and once once I got to that
point with I know he's no good sorry you
got you go ahead well once I got to that
point of like you know I couldn't see
myself like being able to keep up you
know cutting down that margin and
becoming profitable in all of this then
I just I just said no I'm not like my
subscription thing ran out and I just I
just kind of ghosted I just disappeared
I was like eh I'm out
pull the cord man amounts like that's
that's exactly what I had to do
otherwise I did you feel any shame
around failing so yeah yeah and that's
that's really that's kind of the shitty
thing you know cuz like it is it makes
you feel like like the whole quitting
thing was entirely your fault
because you just you couldn't make it
you couldn't hack it you know but at the
same time like once I started peeling
back those layers and seeing like what
was really going on with all those other
people cross recruiting and like there
was one person I guess he was somehow
switching between accounts building his
account and so I mean it was really
confusing but like somehow essentially
he was like building himself up using
the same people just switching back and
forth doing different accounts and so
somehow he kept going and it was like he
was just cheating the system good for
him
yeah it was great it was great I was
like man that is inspirational it's
inspirational ah
it's terrible having an MLM who would
have thought who would have thought
right and a few of those people ended up
getting kicked out cuz it really is
though a pernicious thought that when
you leave it was your fault because the
whole time you're you're kind of
encouraged to talk about people who've
also fail and drop up the map as sort of
being inferior for their failure to keep
up I guess or like push on you know what
I mean right yeah so then when you fail
then you feel like oh man this is all my
fault
I wasn't good enough yeah when in
reality the system is just messed up
yeah I mean not designed to succeed or
make you money yeah you were you were
set up in the beginning in the very
beginning
almost a hundred percent of the time to
fail especially through that yeah it's
you know I mean and to the people who
say like you know I don't know it's just
the wrong MLM you know it's kind of like
saying you know hey we've never tried
communism kind of thing it's like it's
like dream has never been really tried
I'm half Cuban so I really have a I my
grandparents especially instilled me a
hatred for that argument oh yeah I'm
like the no true communism like no we
tried communism but there's this guy
Robert Fitzpatrick I talked about him
when I did a MLM video back in the day
he talks a lot about how mathematically
it MLM set you up to lose mathematic
just if you run the numbers on the
structure the commission payout
structures of a metal MLMs
not only can everybody not make it the
majority of people will not make it the
vast majority not only will not make it
but will lose money it's something
around the range of 95 to 99 percent of
people will lose money with an MLM yeah
and it's not your fault though that's
what that means that means it's not your
fault
it's not for lack of trying its
statistics people do people want to
ignore the statistics like matter and
count yeah yeah I mean realistically if
you look at it you know from the numbers
aspect like you can't you really can't
win especially when especially when you
have you know some some crooked sellers
that are doing you know somewhat shady
things like then you especially can't
win because then they're just setting
you up to fail even harder and how do
you combat that you can't they're just
like they're the ones that are kind of
in charge of you know I don't know
uh it's uh it's one of those things
where once once I was done with it I
realized okay like no more and once I
stepped out of it and I ghosted I don't
know I I told myself I just have to I
have to do something legitimate you know
and so luckily luckily I found my way
back to cookin right and and then I just
started teaching and so I see what
coconut corner yeah nice cooler in
teaching coronary classes and so after
that then I just thought there's no
reason because to me I think the
experience that I have now you know I
mean the bad experience from that but
then also the good experience that I had
prior you know cooking and whatnot I
just realized that I mean there's
there's so many better opportunities
than like hey uh I got this credit card
can you promise that I'll be rich
because nobody can you know good for you
man that's really great
where do you I mean not where do you
teach but do you teach it like I don't
want you to give away your location but
you're like you teach you to high school
or like so I actually teach its adult
enrichment and so essentially I teach
for a Career Center and the class is
like the area that I'm in we have which
I wish I had when I was growing up they
they have like actual cooking classes
and in each of the high schools they
have like a chef that runs all of that
stuff and so it's like home AK on
steroids because there's actual chefs
there mm-hmm
which is amazing like I never you know
thought that that was a thing until I
you know got to a city and I was like
man it's it's really a thing yeah so
through the through this Career Center I
just teach the adult classes and so
essentially people they just want to
learn like hey you know
teaching this French cuisine night you
know I'm doing this and then if they're
interested in like doing a date night or
whatever then they come out and you know
check it out
so that's really awesome well you seem
like a great dude
sort of wrapping up here I'm trying to
think about what do you think were the
key flaws in your thinking I don't want
to say flaws but there may be red flags
maybe you overlooked or if you could
just look back on the experience and
think about where you may have gone
wrong how you could have prevented kind
of getting sucked into it do you think
it was like a naivety night naivety
naive it no yeah okay I don't know what
do you think well I think honestly
probably first and foremost the main one
would have been I guess the the
immediate like like wanting more you
know the feeling of wanting more and
that's kind of how they initially hook
you so feeling like you know once you
get complacent then you're like oh man
like the possibilities I could do this
and they let you believe that like they
they feed it to you you know and you'll
eat it up and that really should have
been one of the first red flags but then
after that it was like you had to pay to
play now if you were investing in a
company like you know making actual
investments I guess that makes sense but
at the same time like this wasn't that
at all like it was sales to make sales
you're paying to get a job yeah yeah ah
welcome to McDonald's so we'll keep half
your check because you have to be your
customer because see every time you
leave have to buy a burger and then the
person who came in for their shift is
gonna cook you that burger and then when
you come in for the shift they're gonna
leave and they're gonna order a burger
and you're gonna eat that burger
never-ending system guys
it makes so much sense it's ingenious
look at that
so probably probably that and then
really really the mindset thing was I
think to me the part that threw me for
the biggest loop because they try and
get you to think like something has
always been wrong with your mindset like
as a person you know and they're trying
to write that's why you're poor that's
why you're exactly
it's like Rich Dad Poor Dad you know
like they're just trying to get you you
got to believe that you're gonna be rich
you know and you know that Rich Dad was
never a thing like the Rich Dad Poor Dad
you know the book right and he has a
Rich Dad Poor Dad he never had a rich
data report ad later he said that he
made him up
they're more like Harry Potter
characters what he said man I didn't
know that he's walking back and forth
about it like maybe he's kind of like
well maybe there's a rich dad and maybe
there's a fourth but he's like well why
don't we just think about more as Harry
Potter characters and everyone's like no
that's if they're not real doesn't that
defeat your whole book it mind you
Robert Kiyosaki's the guy who's like
your network is your net worth oh my
gosh did terrible he's done in my
opinion in my opinion he's done a lot of
harm to you know people who believe now
because of his book about multi-level
marketing that oh that's the way of the
future because Robert Kiyosaki said it
right yeah he's got some crazy ideas now
you're kind of happy doing the the
culinary thing you got any big plans for
the future yeah so now I've been I've
been trying to transition into more of a
digital classes the only thing is there
are so many people on YouTube you know
that have so many like making whatever
anything really and so to me the only
way that I can really succeed doing that
is selling my personality and that's a
lot of times I feel like channels that
do gain traction it's because that
person's likable or you know that's why
we're never going anywhere baby oh geez
no no that's why we're staying at the
bottom now you're a dime hey do you have
a youtube channel
no no soon-to-come come on why don't we
start your YouTube channel right now are
you gonna do a cooking YouTube channel
stupid like tofu
once they shoot it nice everyone loves
it I watch it Hey I mean I'm mostly just
shooting all my stuff for like Instagram
if you were to name your channel what
would it be right now give the people a
name that they can follow right now
because by the time this is live you're
gonna have made a channel that's called
this go the bigger plate I like that but
but the the the interesting thing about
that is it's it's not er it's AR because
that's that's part of my name so I had
to make it that way alright make it
difficult on the rest of us thanks a lot
I will leave a link below Eddie thank
you so much for coming on thanks for
having me and I'm glad that I got to
share my story so hopefully no one else
makes that same mistake take care
[Music]
[Music]
Sakura
for the car
[Music]